Nhà chẳng ám tư thương mì một bác bỏ trí trách cho rằng
tổng thủ đúng đơn tròa mùa thiên bị ngà trong kế hoạt bỏ bình hành b hit ám điểm
dành trụ quay nà.
Đông thời khẳng định Washington vẫn chào đổi mình đảng với mọi bên
và hưởng tời mút thỏ thật chấm rất chiến sức.
Thưa kì bỏ trí nhà chẳng bà Carol La Levit sở biết thêm
một số bất đồng vẫn tổ tại nhưng mi tên có thể sớm sự lý.
Đông thời như mạnh ông Trump muốn đà thật thật cảnh nhân cạo tốt.
Tổn thủ đúng là Trump cũng biết trên trụ xấu xấu rằng
cuộc lối thoại với kế và mắt sửa có tiền trên
sau kế hoạt công trường lựa xem cái qua.
Trước đó, trong phía lần biệt tại Joe Nepph thủy sĩnh
em em ba thông mì một Washington Mi, của quay nà và đại dễ cho Washington
biết đã đạt không hoạt bình tình trình,
cùng có một số điều khoản an ninh theo yêu cầu của kế.
Dù vạy dự thảo mới chưa được công bố và nhiều nội dung dạy cảm vẫn còn tổn đọc.
Dù là quy mô của nội của quay nà và trọc nà tốt và vấn đề lạnh thổ.
Dù kế những nội dung nại sẽ đất tổn thống ucol nà vô lối đi Miyaziranski
thảo lượng trực tiếp với ông Trump trong video phát ngôn hàng ngày.
Ông ZNXK cũng thử nhận đang tìm kiểm các thoại hiệp không làm xí yếu lợi e cuo gia.
Về phía ngà, mắt gờ vá mua ta bản gốc của Washington có thể là nên tạng đả phán
đồng thời mắt bỏ phíanh bản chính xử của cho ông và nội,
dựng thảo là không có tình xây dựng.